wer ihn neue produkte bei bistum und
aliexpress bestellt bekommen haben wir
unter anderem eine reihe von
minderwertigen sachen ein sauger botter
der nicht auf eine drohne die nicht
fliegt ein paar schauer mit verbotenen
substanzen und ein e scooter mit krassen
sicherheitsmängeln also das ist wirklich
gefährlich das ist online shopping auf
einem ganz anderen niveau sie billiger
desto besser und obwohl die qualität der
produkte teilweise echt schlecht ist
gehören die plattformen zu den
beliebtesten shopping apps da stellt man
sich schon die frage wie kann das sein
man muss schon zugeben ist es einfach
auf witzig hier produkte anzuschauen und
sachen zu bestellen die werbung dafür
ist absurd manche dinge sind so
unfassbar billig und andere einfach nur
absolut merkwürdig und sobald ich auf
den seiten bin bekomme ich das gefühl
ich muss jetzt eigentlich etwas
bestellen
und obwohl ich gar nichts brauche will
ich was haben wie das sein kann haben
wir einen experten gefragt da wird
generell so aus einer psychologisch und
perspektive eigentlich alles gemacht was
er in seinem lehrbuch steht damit man
die leute auch zum kaufen verführen
professor kenning ist experte für neuro
marketing das heißt dafür wie man
erkenntnisse aus der psychologie und der
hirnforschung mit marketing verbindet er
kennt also alle tricks die dafür sorgen
können dass wir mehr kaufen als
eigentlich geplant wenn das rein
ökonomisch betrachtet dann haben diese
entsprechenden produkte und angebote
sehr sehr gutes preis
leistungsverhältnis zumindest auf dem
ersten vereinfacht gesagt ist das billig
und willig es ist zeigen uns die seiten
durch streich preise und absurde rabatte
von bis zu 90 prozent habe das gefühl
ich kauf mich reich ja also ich könnte
im prinzip dadurch dass ich etwas kaufe
immer reicher werden weil das konstante
frühere 100 euro jetzt kostet elf euro
also es kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein das
ist ein faktor der sich auf unsere
kaufentscheidung auswirkt ob die rabatte
echt sind oder sich auf verbotene
mondpreise beziehen ist zudem schwer zu
kontrollieren das zweite ist dieses
element der complete even diskordanz ja
wo man versucht den menschen die angst
zu nehmen einen fehlkauf zu tätigen eben
durch die referenzen auf andere die
gekauft haben durch bewertungssystem und
das dritte ist sozusagen dieses thema
der fear of missing out wenn ich das
jetzt nicht drauf und lass' ich weiß was
genau passiert da in unserem kopf immer
dann wenn nicht ein attraktives produkt
sehe dass mein gehirn ein belohnungs
signal erzeugt da sehe ich einen schönen
artikel möchte ihn gerne haben die
zweite struktur ist dann der preis
ich sehe dieses produkt mache ich das
gerne haben schaue jetzt auf dem kreis
und der garant gut das ist aber teuer
und diese beiden dem pulse möchte ich
gerne haben der ist gut und das ist aber
teuer
die werden in den präfrontalen kortex
also unser spiel hierhin projiziert und
da findet jetzt die kontextualisierung
stadt also zum beispiel werden da dann
bestimmte informationen integriert wie
na ja ich habe ja demnächst wieder den
ersten dann habe ich mehr geld und diese
impulskontrolle kann man beeinflussen
und unterdrückten zb über die streich
preise über produktbewertungen über pop
up fenster counter und garantien usw
dazu kommt jetzt noch der game faktor
bei bis zum beispiel gibt es ein
glücksrad und man wird dafür belohnt
wenn man mehr kauft oder einfach dafür
dass man die app jeden tag öffnet jetzt
so spiele mache dann aktiviert quasi
eben das belohnungssystem und wenn ich
jetzt preissenkung mache dann
deaktiviere ich eben dieses preis
schmerzsignale und wenn ich dann auch
sagen jetzt musst du aber schnell kaufen
weil das produkt ist nach erwecken dann
setze ich diese impulskontrolle unter
druck und das führt dann letztendlich zu
diesem manifesten verhalten ja ich finde
den artikel toll bildet unbedingt haben
ich habe weniger kompromisse kontrolle
weil ich ihn abgelenkt wurde ja oder der
druck gesetzt wurde und man gibt mir den
hinweis mensch das ist doch im prinzip
auch total günstig kauft ist ja so und
dann noch mit der starken marke
glücklich ebenfalls eine rolex für 26
euro die schon 6000 leute gekauft haben
da kann ich ja nichts falsch machen
also da muss ich jetzt aber schnell kauf
mehr belohnung weniger schmerz und
weniger impulskontrolle
das ist die neurophysiologische
erklärung wenn sie die autos über diese
plattformen verkaufen würden oder häuser
das würde nicht funktionieren deshalb
geht es um schmuck battles kosmetik
kleidung krimskrams dinge also bei denen
wir nicht ganz so viel nachdenken und
mit viel glück kann man schon ein
schnäppchen machen dass die wenigsten
edle produkte für ein paar euro erwarten
ist auch klar
aber viele verbraucher sind oft auch
gefrustet denn allein bei den sachen die
wir bestellt und getestet haben ist das
ergebnis wirklich bitter von 15
bestellungen sind nur elf überhaupt bei
uns gelandet
und viele der produkte waren gefälscht
in der eu gar nicht zugelassen
minderwertig oder sogar gefährlich es
gibt auch viele menschen die eben dieses
wissen über produktqualitäten nicht
haben und sie sollten das unbedingt
haben müssen weil wir eigentlich eben in
deutschland organisiert haben dass es
kontrollen systeme gibt die dafür sorgen
dass wenn ich produkte kaufe irgend im
handel ich mir nicht so machen muss ob
giftige oder schädigende inhaltsstoffen
sind und genau das klappt aber
offensichtlich nicht ascom produkte an
die nicht sicher sind wenn die
marktüberwachung ist in deutschland noch
nicht im neuland internet angekommen
außerdem haben wir in deutschland ein
recht komplexes system aus
unterschiedlichen ämtern wie für die
marktüberwachung und die
produktsicherheit zuständig sind
der markt ist kaum kontrolliert und wir
verbraucher sind damit nicht wirklich
geschützt als mord an john sorge wenn
man sieht was hier so alles reingepasst
die leute alles so bestellen vor viele
menschen sorgen
jeden tag kommen allein am flughafen
frankfurt etwa 450.000 päckchen an
80 prozent davon aus dem asiatischen
raum dort wo die meisten händler der
plattform produzieren und sitzen nur
damit man eine grobe vorstellung davon
haben allein die bundesnetzagentur hat
im jahr 2018 über zehn millionen online
shopping produkte aus dem verkehr
gezogen weil die produkte gefährlich
weil sie gefälscht oder einfach nicht
gekennzeichnet waren
trotzdem schaffen es viele der produkte
ganz ohne kontrolle zu uns nach hause
das ist vielleicht auch problemen der
coolen aber das ist ein erster hier
eigentlich ein problem sozusagen
derjenigen die die kontrollfunktion
fassen wir also zusammen die plattform
sind extrem billig und sie nutzen viele
strategien um uns zum kaufen zu
animieren
rechtlich gibt es allerdings einiges an
grauzonen und es wird wenig reguliert
aktuell ist der staat mit den kontrollen
überfordert und wir kunden können uns
nicht wirklich darauf verlassen dass wir
ein gutes oder unbedenkliches produkt
bekommen aber natürlich zwingt uns
niemand diese plattform zu nutzen und ob
es wirklich sinnvoll ist sich dort was
zu bestellen wenn man nicht weiß was für
eine qualität man erwarten kann
das muss jeder für sich selbst
entscheiden
[Musik]
habt ihr schon mal was bei jungbusch
oder alle express bestellt wenn ja
schreibt meine kommentare was es war und
ob er damit zufrieden war